I am delighted to learn that there is not
one shred of discrimination of any kind of
the John Hopkins University nor was there
at the University which I have just left I
think it would put me into the political
arena to go beyond this I'm delighted
do you ever feel any personal resentment against
the Democrats for bringing your name into this
campaign I think that would be getting me in
the political discussion and I do assure you
that to the best of my recollection I have never
made a comment in the field of partisan politics
I do not consider the work that I do for the
federal government to be in the character but
a part of the politics the university president
I would consider it unbecoming I don't want to
start now but you think of an individual
survey whether you feel you did or did not
appease their own government of Argentina I I
don't think that I can divorce myself from the
presidency of Hopkins and take more follow dr.
Ivan our do you have any political ambitions
for faith presidency I have never had any and do
not have any now that almost violated my father